[Musique]
avec bruno mégret restons maîtres chez
nous oui c'est vrai il faut rester
maîtres chez nous il faut nous faire
respecter comme peuple et comme nation
aujourd'hui c'est tout le contraire
c'est en grand désordre qui s'abat sur
le pays
l'insécurité explose l'immigration est
de plus en plus massive la france
s'appauvrit les impôts s'alourdissent
les familles sont bafoués les valeurs
s'inversent et tout cela devant des
politiciens interchangeables qui se
succèdent sans jamais rien changé
vous en avez assez moi aussi j'en ai
assez et c'est pourquoi je suis candidat
et je vous le dis ça peut changer
on peut remettre de l'ordre dans notre
pays c'est possible mais pour cela il
faut cesser de voter toujours pour les
mêmes il ne faut plus se laisser dicter
notre vote par les médias ou par les
sondages qu'il faut voter avec notre
coeur
notre intelligence et notre instinct moi
j'ai incarné le renouveau je le fais pas
de fausses promesses
je veux simplement remettre la france à
l'endroit
je vous propose un vrai changement pour
assurer le renouveau de la république et
de la france
pour remettre de l'ordre en france
maigret à l'elysée
[Musique]